hello and welcome to this webinar
dedicated to the interference of biotin
on immunoassays my name is
françois guibert is part of
the marketing department of abbott
diagnostics and will be the moderator
of today's session this webinar is
organized by  the august ball is
sponsored by abu d'agnostics if you
want to know more about the activities
of abbott diagnostic
i invite you to find me on the
website www corps laboratory point
abbott
but if you want it let's start
now however before starting
I would like to remind you that this
session is interactive,
that is to say that at any time you
can ask the speaker a question by
pressing the box as questions by
entering your question and pressing
on stage you depending on the time
remaining  at the end of the presentation we
will answer as many questions as
possible the others will be answered
individually by the speaker and the
answers sent to the  questions to
people while they have asked them
if you have problems seeing
or hearing this webinar well click
on the support tab at the top right of
the presentation window or
report your problem by entering it
in the
ask box  question it is therefore the pleasure to
introduce you to marie piketty biologist
at the necker hospital in paris and who will make
the presentation of this day marie picque
and has practiced there since 1985 in many
French hospitals and is
now part of the department of  hormones at
home and exploration of
bone metabolism and reno at necker hospital in
paris she
is a recognized expert in france
for hormonal and metabolic assays
you can find her
complete biography by going to the
biography tab located on your screen
marie piketty I give you the floor
to start your presentation
hello everyone and welcome to the
biotin seminar on the road
biotin the interference of  biotin has
been the subject of a lot of ink for
some time and indeed it is too
many errors in recent
years numerous cases of false
biological hyperthyroidism have been
reported and the main
international newspapers have echoed
it.  are worried because these false
hyperthyroidism have caused
unnecessary additional investigations and
sometimes inappropriate treatments
for the patient the common point of all
these cases of false hyperthyroidism was
in fact the patients taking high doses of
biotin and then there is
a  little more than a year at the end of November 2010,
an alert from the American
agency fbi fell there this security alert
addressed to all health actors
but also to the general public and this
alert followed the death of  a
passion patient who was having a
myocardial infarction and chirac the troponin had not been
seen to rise because of the
intake of biotin and because of a dosage
which was sensitive to the interference of
the biotin which had two bought had
been used for two and the troponin
in this patient also what is
happening with this guillotine what is
biotin we will see that
biotin is capable of
bidirectional interference it is to  to say
falsely increased
results and falsely decreased results we
will see how to attenuate this
interference and in which situation on the
contrary this interference can be
exacerbated we can say that biotin
for biology is like the holidays
news we are going to see how to manage these
parties news what is biotin first
of all biotin it is a
vitamin which is called us tamin bin 8
in france for the anglo saxons it
is the habitat mines bessette and
for the germans  it is the Thames h
it is a
vitamin which is present in
very many foods its
recommended intake is around 30
micrograms and this intake is largely
achieved with a diet  classic ion
and even the intestinal flora of
bacteria is able to provide us
with biotin also the true
biotin deficiency is a very rare situation in
which there are neurological disorders
and disorders of the
hair of the skin and appendages at the
point of view  metabolic biotin
coenzyme des carbo xigaze participate
in the mitochondria you see
here in the production of energy in the form
of atp and biotin is also involved
in the synthesis of fatty acids in
the five-six that auplata synthesis
of amino acids  and in neoglauco
genesis in which situation
can we encounter
high doses of bertine in a patient
first of all in
hereditary metabolic diseases such as
bio deficits timid to
mitochondrial diseases these are patients in
whom high doses  of biotin
are administered. This is a
rare situation and for which the care is
specific and hospital-based with
very specialized services recently a
new context of taking biotin
has appeared biotin taken this time
as a food supplement so
let us specify right away that the
vitamin cocktails that can be
found on the market contain a
quantity of biotin of 30
micrograms  that is to say the normal recommended dose
and that this small dose of 30
micrograms of will pose a problem at
any dosage, on the other hand, recently
a new mode of
food supplements very loaded with biotin has appeared
with doses of biotin representing 2.5
30 mg per day  that is to say a thousand times
the recommended daily intake and its
special biotin food supplements
are supposed to improve the skin and the
hair
here the examples of these
biotin food supplements as they can be
found in commerce
the bottle violated at the top right was
to appear in the window of a hairdresser
in my street what to realize is
in biot t-il not the sta  drug
and that we can get it freely
without any restriction and without any
control while it is in France
the prevalence of these
food supplements containing high doses
of biotin today nobody knows how to
answer this question we  we have
no precise statistics
last september was published a study carried out at
the mayo clinic in the united states the
biologists of the mayo clinic had
distributed questionnaires in the
waiting rooms of the mayo clinic and
the patients of these rooms  expectations
declared taking a
biotin-based food supplement loaded with
biotin in seven 7% of the responses to the
questionnaire
the biologists wanted to go
further and measured biotin in
all patients who went to
the mayo clinic emergency room is actually for 7
4  % of patients seen in the mayo clinic emergency department
had serum biotin levels greater than 10
nanograms per milliliter
this  the concentration of 10 nanograms
per milliliter corresponds to a high threshold
from which the interference will
appear for the assays most
sensitive to biotin and what about
in France we do not know in 2007 there was
indeed a report  on the
eating habits of the French,
but this report reports on a
survey carried out in the years 2014
2015 at a time when biotin was
not yet a fashion phenomenon at a
time when we were not yet talking about
biotin from  elsewhere the word biotin
does not appear in this report,
however this report indicates that approximately
29% of adults in France absorb
food supplements,
however their definition of a
food supplement was very broad since
even a 6th for them and a
food supplement also for
France we only have indirect indicators
such as this map
which maps
google consultations on biotin and
this with the keywords b  iotin and
hair and with this map we can
see that the craze for
biotin seems to concern mainly
the Anglo-Saxon world the good
news comes in fact from our
dermatologist colleagues who point out in this
publication that in fact there is a
disproportion  between this
huge enthusiasm for biotin and the absence of
proven clinical facts, the absence of
demonstration of the effect of very high
doses of biotin on the hair and on
the skin and this article therefore concludes
that taking high doses of biotin
corresponds to a glamorous fashion which is
very widely relayed by social networks
by the media but which in fact is
not based on any clinical fact
so we can hope that this
glamorous fashion will end up stopping by itself for
lack of results  finally the third
situation where one can encounter
supraphysiological doses of biotin
corresponds to multiple sclerosis which
to the demyelinating disease and for
multiple sclerosis all starts  Particularly
in the faith in the progressive hand of
multiple sclerosis
because a
beneficial trial could be demonstrated in
about 12% of his patients and it is
beneficial that one explains by the fact
that biotin promotes the synthesis of
myelin and by the  fact that biotin
as we have seen participate in the
production of atp which could
promote neuronal conduction on
the demyelinating axons of multiple
sclerosis multiple sclerosis is a disease
that is common in france it is estimated
that there are approximately  120 thousand patients who
suffer from this disease is the
progressive form of multiple sclerosis would
concern approximately thirty thousand
patients in France since June 2016
a temporary authorization
for use has been granted in France
for very high doses of biotin
under the name of  a drug
called that they have which represents
a dose of three times 100 mg per day,
that is to say about ten thousand times the
recommended daily dose  which we
talked about earlier
this delivery is only
hospital it is a drug that you
cannot find in
town pharmacies and therefore there is a cohort with a
biotin cohort with this atheist had
you should know that the news
inclusion in this biotin cohort
were interrupted last October
and are kept in this
biotin cohort only patients who
have been able to record a beneficial effect of biotin
what you should know finally
is that patients who have a seven
also have thyroid check-ups very
frequently
because many MS treatments, in
particular the intruder of mahb and
interferon, are treatments that
promote neither the phenomenon of
thyroid autoimmunity and because of this it is
patients who should have thyroid monitoring
closer
then  we summarize the three
main supraphysiological intakes of biotin you
ensure hereditary
metabolic diseases and
demyelinating diseases are the  situations where the
intake of biotin where the dose of biotin
is the highest this is the situation where
the interference will be the most
intense is no longer ample but it is
also specific recruitments with
well identified patients and in
what  when it comes to multiple
sclerosis patients have to carry a
biotin
card with them and they have to show that card every
time they go to a lab and
maybe the most
worrying situation is actually
supplements  food supplements to the
extent that a patient who takes
food supplements will
not necessarily report this intake of
food supplements because for the patient
if it is not prescribed by a doctor
it does not deserve to
be reported while  does it in our age buzz in the
presence of biotin to understand
the interference of biotin it must be
remembered that in immunoassays at the
end of incubation it is always  bear
necessary to separate the
antibody antigen complexes from the
reaction medium it is these
antibody antigen complexes that carry the signal
that we will measure
it can be a light signal without
phosphorescent water or more recent or in
ssii matic whatever signal
the interference of biotin does
not depend on the nature of the signs a on the other hand
when the separation of the
antigen-antibody complexes involves the
bond stripped abidin biotin it is
there that will occur the interference because
the free biotin in the serum of the
patient will block all the
stripped abidin sites of the solid phase
and will therefore prevent inhibit the separation
of the complexes and therefore will inhibit the
measurement of the signal there is therefore a loss of
signal
linked to the complex antigens antibodies a
loss of the signal linked to measure in hymn
an analysis there are two
assay principles the first principle and the
sandwich assay which has an increasing calibration curve
this short of calibration  ge it
always presents the signal as it goes and in the
ordinate and in the abscissa the concentration
of the hormone at two and if we lose the
signal by losing the complex main imans
which could not and
separate because of the biotin you see  that on
a court or increasing
it will result in an error by default
we will underestimate
the hormone canton d'eauze sandwiched in the
presence of biotin what do we
dare not sandwich today  these are
all the pituitary hormones the in
regulation mode the pth dropped I neither
I was hungry also the tire globulin
the catatonia the pancreatic hormones
insulin and it is small but also
the cardiac markers of the
tumor markers procalcitonin and
numerous serologies, on the contrary, the
second principle of dosage used in
an analysis and the principle by
competition which, on the contrary, has a
decreasing calibration curve on
this decreasing curve if the antigen complexes are lost.
ticorps and therefore if
we lose signal on the
decreasing curve it will result on the contrary
in an error seemed to be the opposite of the
sandwich
why don't we dare in competition
today it's essentially
all the small molecules
it's  that is to say free t3 and t4 all
steroids cortisol estradiol
testosterone the a25 wesh vitamin d
the berries of this pole to many
drugs and also many
autoantibodies and in particular the
anti tsh receptor antibody then the
result c  is therefore an
unfortunate association of falsely
increased results and falsely
decreased results and the association of the two
will simulate an endocrine balance sheet which has
all the appearances of consistency
but which is in fact totally artificial
totally false as for example for
the thyroid  a very high t4 nîmes
associated with a collapsed tsh with the added bonus
of the false positive anti-tsh receptor antibody
you see that the trap is perfect you
have to  recognize
and this balance sheet has all the appearances of a
completely coherent Graves' disease hyperthyroidism balance sheet in the same
way we can observe a 25 at
the so-called very high vitamin ages
associated with a collapsed p th as if it
there was vitamin d intoxication
we could also observe a
falsely increased cortisol level associated
with a collapsed h plate as if there
were a hyper corti 6 mhz and a
very high testosterone associated with fsh
and collapsed cows as a sign there was
for example  a testicular mother and her
results will be obtained in
patients who have no endocrine problems of
which you see these
results are entirely created by
the interference of biotin these
are kiosk facts
because if we look at all the
techniques  that we have for dosing
the hormones
you see on this table the very large
number of techniques that they use
the interaction stripped abidine
guillotine for two and  the hormones
appear in blue all the
sandwich assays which will have a
greatly reduced result
and appear in red all the
techniques by competition which will
give us a falsely
increased result in the presence of biotin then
these data are those which appear
in the supplier instructions they are
also those  which have been transmitted
by the security alerts which have
multiplied in recent
years
the figures which you see appearing
are the concentrations of biotin
from which the interference of
biotin will manifest
itself taking as a definition of
the  interference a note greater than
10% the
lower the concentration of biotin, the
more interference will occur
quickly and the more the assay will be
sensitive to interference from biotin
so you see what we observe
we observe that this  sensitivity
to biotin interference will
vary greatly from one technique to another
.  also very variable even from the
same supplier
the sensitivity to biotin will be very
very very diversified
a comparable census was carried
out last fall under the auspices of
the ifc it is for cardiac markers
troponin and natriuretic peptides
including  moreover the
biology tests delocalize which we call pct
point-of-care testing you see here
again many techniques
use the straight
abidine guillotine technology with sensitivities
to interference which will be very
diverse
finally I wanted to show you this
nice study done listing
rapid pregnancy tests this
team compared different
pregnancy tests for
biotin interference and it was quite relevant
is justified insofar as it
is that in the population it is
especially women 18 to 45 who
take dietary supplements
so you see this study that was
conducted as well a lifetime too  on the
left side of the slide that in
vivo in women taking 10 mg of
biotin doses used in cosmetics
you see that indeed there were
1-1 rapid pregnancy tests
called quick view and which is sensitive
to  biotin and which will not give
satisfactory results in women
who take biotin so if we
try to find out what is the percentage
of laboratories in France which use
these techniques streit abidin biotin
with this sensitivity to the interference
of biotin by examining  the results
of the external quality assessment of
pro bio cale in 2018
the percentage of laboratory in the
technique depends on the binding stripped
abidine guillotine varied see according to
the tests between 40 and 60% both
for hormone assays and for
cardiac marker assays
so why such popularity in
the current ten minutes 2 age then what
needs to be understood is that
streptom binding  ycine biotin it is a
very high affinity bond it is
practically a covalent bond and
which therefore makes it possible to go very quickly and a
very fast and very robust bond
with facilities for amplifying the signal
and therefore improving a limit of
detection
it is also very easy to
innate biotin of biological molecules because
this biotin inez biotin isation
forgiveness is very easily done both
of course antigens and antibodies
without modifying the immunoreactivity of its
molecules
so the result is that it  is these
tests using the stripped
abidin guillotine bond are very widespread
in
very high-speed assays in biology
relocate in rapid tests
this trept abidin biotin bond is
also widely used in many
techniques in research technical elisa
using micro then coated with
streptomycin and  also
immunohisto china techniques
so here are
biotin assays we have  ns produced with a
mass spectrometry technique in
different situations you see the
first two situations 5 mg x 3 10 mg
x of sentences are doses that are
absorbed for cosmetic purposes in red
you see doses that are taken
in the sclerosis protocol in  plates in
France and then other very
high doses also used in
multiple sclerosis 200 mg in one dose 300 mg in
one dose and finally completely on the right
the situation of hereditary metabolic diseases
then see the physiological concentrations appear in yellow
of biotin
which are always less than 1.2
nanograms per millilitre, that is to say at the
very bottom of the scale and you see
appearing here in the bar that you
see appearing it is the sensitivity
of the tests which are the most  sensitive
to biotin which you see the
very important impact that this biotin can
have in all these situations
so what are the determinants of
this interference
so we have seen an important determinant
is the type of dosage we have seen that the
different dosages are variously
sensitive to biotin and probably in
particular because of the volume of the
death intake which is variable and which will
provide a quantity  of bio thing eggs
in the reaction medium which will be
variable another very
important determinant of interference is the
time elapsed since the last intake of
bio thing because we know that
the highest concentration will be
observed in both  hours and therefore
the maximum impact of the intolerance
will be around two hours
after taking it and then the other
very important determinant of the interference is
the dose of biotin absorbed by the
patient in the most difficult situations.
problems being that of the
highest doses, particularly in multiple sclerosis
and then finally the last
very important determinant of the interference is
the patient's renal function because the
of outines and é  eliminate essentially
by the rhine at 100% and therefore patients
who have impaired renal function will
take much longer to
eliminate biotin so how
can we deal with this
interference then the first of
the most obvious solutions to
this problem  in a patient it is
to stop the biotin and re dose and
then in reindeer the guillotine so when
the patient takes doses of biotin
used as cosmetics
we know for example that for a dose of
10 mg it is enough to wait  24 hours
to be able to dose back to the basic state,
however if the dose is higher than
30 mg per day it will be necessary
to wait longer and a
waiting period of two days will be necessary
because 24 hours cannot  not be
enough if you have taken 30 mg per day
so stopping taking biotin is
of course what is recommended knowing
that for these doses the half-life of
biotin will be around 15 hours
but  there's  there are situations that will
still cause us problems, particularly
in multiple sclerosis
the very high doses used
how long should we stop before being able to
dose correctly we know with the
many cases of postponement that have appeared
over the past three years that  to be
able to 2 and t3 t4 tsh it will be necessary to
wait
- four days before being able to dose
correctly but in the case of
the anti latte h receptor antibody it
will be necessary to wait
longer because this assay is more
sensitive biotin it will be necessary
to wait 7 to 15 days for
antibodies a small
landing receptor and for other
hormonal assays but we do not know
exactly
on the other hand in the context of
renal failure
how long should we wait before
to be able to dose correctly,
we know, for example, that in
end-stage renal failure with a
single dose of 10 mg, the artifact observed
on the pdh assay persisted  for
fifteen days this
is the reason why the
stopping time necessary before being able to
dose is in fact very variable this is the
reason why awake in
his alert of November 2017 specified that
no recommendation was
really possible no
recommendation of stopping how
concerning the period during which
it is necessary to stop the boot before being
able to dose correctly because this delay
of a necessary will be very variable
according to the tests and according to the dose taken
by palpation and according to the
renal function of the  patient on the other hand in the
case of a hereditary
metabolic disease such as bio
petit zidane deficiency it will be impossible
to stop biotin unless
neurological deficits appear,
therefore the prescriber will purely
and simply refuse to stop biotin  and
then finally of course in the context of an
emergency there can be no question
of stopping biotin for several days
before being able to become nauseous so there is
other solutions than stopping
biotin which must be thought out and
organized in order to be able to solve this problem this
is the reason why we
had developed a technique to
neutralize biotin techniques
whose protocol you see appearing you will
not be able to  return a result after
seeing neutralize the biotin only on
condition of having revalidated your two
ages
after this neutralization of a biotin
and on condition also in framing
your process with
negative controls positive controls
so what strategies can we
design  in relation to this problem
of buzine interference then the
first thing of course is to
know all the dosages that will
potentially be impacted and therefore it is
necessary to identify in the laboratory
all the dosages present that they
will implement the
streptomycin biotin binding to separate
complex humans not to mention rapid tests
not to mention
del biology tests  localize once this
inventory of techniques has been made it
will be necessary to classify them in
competition and sandwiched so as to be
able to anticipate in which direction
the interference will manifest itself to
help you identify the interference
when it will occur will be
necessary  also to identify the
possibilities of alternative dosage that
you with close colleagues and in
particular with the help of
alternative techniques which do
not use this restored the ty may in particular for
the dosages which can fall under
the emergency troponin h he gets and  this is
the second point of strategies for the
biotin problem and to organize
information in the widest
possible way towards patients and
towards prescribers and on the
reports of the analyzes for each
test to show with the result
the mention caution incorrect dosage in the
event of taking biotin, specifying the
direction of the interference results
falsely positive  ifs or false
negatives depending on whether we are in competition
or in a sandwich this is the copy of the
card
that the patients who trumpet plated
who take biotin for this
potting soil in plates this
is the card that these
patients wear  which must present in
all laboratories
the third point of biotin strategies
and to do everything to obtain the
training is that the patient
biotin treatment this is
crucial information and especially in
the case of outpatients if you
have a post  of taking when
taking the gold and even when
making an appointment it is necessary
to specifically ask the question is
what you are taking from the burthe they
worked in the hospital there is also the
possibility of obtaining the  information with
computer means, in particular
because in multiple sclerosis the
drug which tended to be
exclusively hospital delivered and therefore to the
possibility by connecting to the l  dispensing software
from our
pharmacist colleagues to obtain information
on whether the patient is taking it, which
tended at the time of stopping the
new biotin inclusion in the cohort
we know that there were approximately
7,500 patients in France who
advocated  biotin at very high doses of multiple
sclerosis once we have the information of course
we will attach the information in the
biological file as
permanent information
third point of the biotin strategy
which is to eliminate the interference of
biotin first by asking harp dream
after stopping biotin when
possible and we have seen that it is not
always possible in a satisfactory way
or then alerted the prescriber
to inform him that we have interference on
the dosage because of the biotin and
give it the direction of the interference or
else controlled with an
alternative technique provided that it is
very easily available then the
last solution proceeds the  depletion
of ours and biotin and
neutralize the biotin on condition
of having 20
and for the assay revalidate the assay
after neutralization reported that the
technique of dilutions which is a
strategy very often used when
looking for interference in
laboratories unfortunately  it's
dilution does not allow us to
solve the problem of interference
in the swimming pool because when we have a
treatment for multiple sclerosis
the 12.2 biotin are the ones that we
will have to proceed to dilutions at least
to the 100th for  to be able to get rid of
the interference of biotin and when we
say lu hao hundredths we will go
below the limit of quantification
of the dosage
so we will not be able to give a result
what do we have as a perspective
compared to  this problem which has arisen in
france for three years what we expect
as prospects - already yields a little
better to know this interference and in
particular to better understand  end the
biological variability of its half-life its
half-life is on average 15 hours
but in fact it ranges from 8 hours to 19
hours depending on the patient we are waiting to
better know what is the possible impact
of metabolites can bind on the
structure  in and to better understand
the action of abb yachting in the
metabolisms, but what we are of course expecting
as a perspective is an
improvement in the dosages or the
detection of biotin and it is quite
obvious that the suppliers must
respond to  this new risk and
improve the biotin tolerance of
their dosage there is a pressing need
for innovation but as you
can imagine it is not in fifteen days
convard form validated a dosage so
it takes time
is what  we can retain as a
conclusion in relation to this
biotin seminar what we must retain from people
is the very particular behavior
of this interference which is
bidirectional and which therefore implies an
understanding of the mechanic  anism of
the interference to be able to spot it
this interference appeared at the
start essentially by
false thyroid or biological worms and that is
no coincidence it is because the
patients with a generous number of
plaques have very  often
thyroid check-ups and there are many
treatments for multiple sclerosis
that will be able to manage an
authentic thyroid problem also in the
face of any biological hyperthyroidism if
your techniques are sensitive to alioune
tine
it is imperative to call the
prescriber for any check-up
hyperthyroidism so as to know the
clinical context of this
hyperthyroidism alongside
hyperthyroidism other
hormonal assessments may be misleading in
particular you are simulating
an endocrine pathology such as hyper corti may 6
vitamin d poisoning a
clinical confrontation is therefore  always
essential in hormones at home and if
this interference by its
bidirectional character  therefore
particularly concerns endocrinology it
must also be remembered that this biotin
will be artifacts and the damon assays are
not only the two moon agents and in
particular all the other immunoassays
may be artifacts and by
biotin and this in a very intense way
streptomycin biotin today is
therefore a very widespread technology
in laboratories but it has a heel
magda chine which is the supra
physiology intake of biotin which was
once extremely rare which was in fact
before formerly limited to
hereditary diseases of metabolism it is to  to say
in very rare situations to manage
this biotin interference there is
therefore an information strategy to
obtain the information that a patient is
taking biotin this strategy
training is absolutely crucial so
we are faced with a new
deal which  is that a significant number
of patients daily absorb a
mems component of our two ages
, which gives  e a very significant potential for artefacts
it is therefore a
completely
new situation because it is unheard of and
therefore this new situation represents
a new challenge for
biologists but also for
reagent suppliers who must
make their reagent resistant to
biotin as well as for all the
clinicians
thank you for your attention and
therefore I am ready to answer your
questions
thank you very much marie piketty for this
presentation which is both very clear and
very complete and therefore during this
presentation of the  questions have come
here is the first question an
urgent request for troponin comes in urgently and
the patient reports that he is taking
biotin what would you advise to do
so yes this is a burning question
if you have a technique that uses
the stripped abilene bond  biotin
you are asked for an urgent matter and the
patient take the biotin first
solution you call the prescriber and
wanted to point out that you have an
interference with the troponin dosage
and that you will not be able to give him a
reliable result
it is a first solution not very
satisfactory since the patient will
not have his troponin dosage and at least
the emergency doctor will not  will not rely on a
crazy result second solution you
immediately have an alternative technique available that
does not use
streptomycin biotin and you are
implementing
it it may also be a question of a
relocating biology technique with
which you will make a
troponin dosage without the interference of
biotin you will simply then have to
explain to the prescribers of the two
results which one is reliable
and on which it will be able to rely
third solution you neutralize
biotin with the protocol I
mentioned  it is a solution that you can
implement only if you have
carried out your dosage
after neutralization of the biotin priem
solution  but there is no fourth
solution
here
thank you very much for your your answer
to a second question you showed
the techniques using this very small
sensitive biotin viking j cardiac markers
and rapid pregnancy tests
to your knowledge
does it exist  also a census for
rapid diagnostic orientation tests his
call and rhodes for hiv
it is a good question indeed to
my knowledge a
comparable census has not yet been carried out
for rapid hiv tests it would
be quite interesting this  either that or
it is that these techniques will be explored
in relation to the problems
of victim interference thank you for
your new answer
this is the third question that comes to
your attention
are there any plans to introduce
samples with  biotin in
external quality assessment programs
I haven't heard of it yet
but that would be very
relevant is all  interestingly
that is an external
quality assessment that explores the response of a
thyroid assay or other assay in
case of patients taking
biotin provided they have a
clinical background that allows biologists
to be wary and  to suspect
the interference it would be very
interesting if this is organized as
part of an external evaluation of cannes
and of course thank you for this answer
we still have time for a
question are you not afraid
that a  warning sentence on
the interference of biotin does not
overload the analyzed reports in a too complex way
does not harm
the clarity and the league b
sorry for the readability of the results
indeed we always have the concern
to have  a dreger report not that it
is perfectly readable and is
perfectly clear for the prescriber
nevertheless with the
apple laboratory computers one can in fact m a
warning sentence on the  biotin
in a way that's not going to harm and that's
not going to overload the record and
that's a phrase that we
put in place two and a half years ago and
we welcome that because it's really
a pedagogical virtue with  of all the
prescribers who now think about
this interference and it also has a
preventive virtue where they pay attention
to asked the patients are you
taking the guillotine for us it's
really a very important sentence to
put on the record  by
arranging so that the report
remains easily readable vicious
again a big thank you marie piketty
for this presentation for her
answers to the questions before
leaving us before concluding do you have a
last comment to make concerning
this webinar a last conclusion of
synthesis I believe that to conclude
the interference of biotin
once again gives an example of what the
confrontation a clinic and the
clinical dialogue with the  prescriber and
always for the biologist
the best way to detect and
fight against interference in the
immuno of sage
thank you thank you again marie
piketty for this very beautiful
presentation for the very
clear answers to the questions asked
and then thank you to the bush of  having
ensured the organization of this webinar
before leaving us, I would like to point out
again that for the questions that have
been asked and that we will not have
had time to deal with during the webinar,
an answer will be sent by e-mail by
Madame piketty  at the address that was
given during the
webinar description, I also specify
that this webinar can be seen for
six months on the la brousse website and la
brousse will also send you an
e-mail following this webinar so for
you  inform you to give you the
link to connect to this webinar
and we also suggest that
you forward this link to
your acquaintances and your colleagues who may
not have p  u see the webinar
live and who would like to see it again
afterwards thank you again for your
participation in this webinar and see you very
soon